i want to give you some words to live by
by our friend
steve jobs oh steve jobs we all got our
apple phone in our hands steve jobs
steve um he basically says according to
steve jobs all highly intelligent people
share this one
trait oh god oh god i need the strength
do you need this dude and awkward if you
don't have the straight you don't well i
have it and i didn't have it at one
point
but it all has to do
with the big picture oh understanding
the big
picture steve jobs says this a lot of
what it means to be smart is the ability
to zoom out
like you're in a city and you can look
on the whole city from the 80th floor
down and while other people are trying
to figure out how to get from point a to
point b micro moves yeah
using these little maps is what he says
yeah you could see it all in front of
you and you can see the entire thing
open up so the question is how do you
develop this bird's eye
view so job says you have to not have
the same bag of experiences
as everyone else oh shout out bronies
kids okay
or else you're gonna make some the same
connections and you won't be innovative
basically saying do some wild different
[ __ ] yeah think outside the box don't do
what everybody else does
carve your own path he says this um
and these are some
weird random examples but
think about going to paris and becoming
a poet for a few years okay
go to a third world country and donate
your time fall in love with two people
at once see how that works out
and by the way do you know that walt
disney took a lot of lsd okay
uh now look i'm not saying that you need
to go to paris and become a poet or that
you need to drop lsd at disney world
right sounds like fun
not exactly in the cards though um but
basically saying is be different stand
out think
outside the box not the typical nine to
five lifestyle that most people do find
ways to spice up your life keep it spicy
yeah right you know most people like i
say at the beginning of the show most
people are most people
most people are going through the
motions most people are broke yeah most
people won't take the time out of their
day to listen to a show like this most
people don't even do a freaking budget
yeah most people don't save that money
most people certainly don't invest that
money most people are most people most
people are thinking short term yeah
they're thinking what am i up to this
weekend how do i get oh my god how do i
get to the week how do i get to the next
page how do i get to the next paycheck
then oh my god thank god it's friday oh
my god monday's coming here it's the
weekend on paycheck to paycheck
experience experience most people are
most people yeah but what steve jobs is
saying is like dude
and a lot of it does have to do with how
much money you have in your bank account
because what happened to me was once i
stopped focusing on week to week month
to month
i can start thinking year to year
beyond year to year where do i want to
be in five years from now this is what
they call the bird's eye view so a lot
of it has to do with saving your money
it's so i always say this thing i don't
save money so i can buy things i save
money so i can do things money buys the
opportunity buys you opportunities it
buys you perspective and the more money
you save the more things you can do with
them and the more things you can do the
bigger picture that you can have yeah
that's what it's all about it's not
about buying it so you can get a new
gucci belt or push a new car a new whip
or have a nicer couch in your house it's
like yo
how can i do some [ __ ] that i'm planning
five years from now yeah some long-term
perspectives just zoom out some zoom out
some yeah some all right cool here's
where i'm at now but if i can do this
and do this and do this
all right five years from now here's
where i want to be yeah dude okay yeah
when i started this show it was just me
with a hey what's up guys i think you
should save that money look at me now
valuetainment long-term perspective
um
so basically shout out to steve jobs for
making us think outside the box making
us
do the things that are unconventional
yeah right
like even when i started my financial
job i was faced with two options okay go
the conventional route and i was living
in miami stay in miami work for a friend
he was a little shady you know miami
shady place sunny uh sunny place shady
people yeah or go all the way to boca an
hour north and work for this financial
firm and start off as a cold caller
making no money and i had to balance
that i said well look you know that the
easy route is just staying in miami and
with all my friends and
and you know living
with my buddy and that's the easy route
yeah the difficult route is moving up to
boca where i didn't know anybody an hour
away whether it's an hour away or a
different state
taking a chance betting on yourself
doing some out there stuff
yeah and betting on yourself
and that's what i did
dude that's that's that resonates a lot
with what you you just said the easy and
the hard
something i learned
uh
shout out kara harpist this my
ex-girlfriend this is like a big thing
in um
well from seven years i mean we were
together for a long time okay but
something that we always talked about
that she always told me was like dude
the difficult thing is always like
usually the right thing to do
you could it's oe like you said it's
easy i could easily stay here and do
this thing that's the easy thing to do
the thing you don't want to do the hard
thing is probably the right thing to do
well you know they kind of chase that
feeling shout out to her and you know
they say
um if it was easy
everyone would do it dude yeah
if it was easy everyone would do it you
know that that was
my one of my best friends is the guy
chris humphries the guy that married kim
k yeah we talked about that in the
episode that's his whole thing
if it was easy everyone will do it yeah
oh you're a loser bro like
yeah you made it to the nba you only
made this amount of you didn't even play
all that much you got divorced from kim
k oh yeah bro you do it did you make it
to the nba did you marry kim k shut up
yeah
it was easy everyone would do it yeah so
anyway
steve jobs
the departed the wise uh thank you
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken